this next one is from Bruno from Toronto
another guy come on [ __ ] what's going
on Brennan I got a debate club for you
Game of Thrones or Avengers hmm Gang
Gang buzz buzz
thanks so much love the show piece this
guy definitely looks is a NASA Chiron
and he looks like an actual astronaut if
ya don't eat that was an astronaut I'd
buy it
yeah there's no way he doesn't play an
astronaut or a astronaut young buddy
that's kind of like Loki shadowing him
in every movie looks like a NASA intern
no he looks like more than an intern
intern Vic yeah it was too young to be
uh but he looks like he has a shot at
going into space yeah I agree dude it
looks like um Game of Thrones or
Avengers and I listen man I don't [ __ ]
with Avengers I [ __ ] with the game of
throne you do
oh I'm balls deep in the game of Thrones
you ever seen a white Walker do you ever
seen a [ __ ] dragon you've heard Clay
Walker they're the [ __ ] musician nope
don't give a [ __ ] really good you ever
seen Billy see her hair's long no 64 she
was born either huh Khaleesi hit on
Khaleesi before that show was big at a
UH you a scumbag I hit on her
appropriately first was Lindsay Lohan
now it's the queen of the dragons dude I
put a note in her lair in the door that
said if she was up late and bored that I
was hey I'm next door if you're up late
and bored I'm wide awake next door
staring into your window the we're here
cuz no weird that is and you're probably
in a robe what was it in a robe rosin it
great are you doing next Lindsay law and
she was like 17 then no she was not
seven yeah she was bro we were both a
yo-yo
[ __ ] no I even remember looking the IMDB
of Parent Trap to make sure there's no
age yeah what are we saying what are we
even talking about getting an app game
I don't watch either one of them I'll
tell you this what is good though is
just the ten of us reruns can you bring
a
for that just the 10 of us yeah we'll
talk about one man in [ __ ] nine
hotties living an apartment together you
could not make this TV show today 1987
yeah can we zoom in on that no we're
just gonna guess what I believe more in
dragons than I do this ball dude having
all these chicks hot chicks to row up
for debate well that's a dude on the
left there no that one is underage on a
far bottom for now it's a dude bro
anything can happen
yeah you're right 1987 though you gotta
stay a dude but when you have ten kids
you can [ __ ] lose a kid bro at the
mall dude you don't care who gives off
oh boy no more gonna be a thicker
Christmas for the rest of us if we lose
one more sheets so gang that's a great
show if you get to find those reruns
yeah I don't watch all that kind of
stuff man but if I'm gonna I'd rather
see somebody watch anything do you like
watch Netflix I mean I watch Dateline
really yeah I guess Dateline what else
do you do I love missing people and I
love they had a show called disappear
but they couldn't find anybody else that
was missing would you like that Ron
crime drama like first 48
you look like temp do that Jax off the
Law & Order oh is that what I look like
dude no I don't what else we got it was
51% of people said Game of Thrones yeah
baby show of all time
yep you almost really yeah name close
that's just cuz Breaking Bad gave up
pretty bad was weak you know bro they
shot an infant out there I don't know
Breaking Bad teacher selling drugs all
right I'm out
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching